let's go next to our caller from the
seven one nine area code who's calling
today from seven one nine
this is Lamont hey Lamont what's doing
here me yes I got hey David I'm a big
fan of the show I was a Bernie Sanders
delegate in 2016 and I am still
supporting him today I am also though a
Christian and a socialist and that kind
of puts me in kind of a dichotomize
position my question was I believe that
Jesus was a liberal revolutionary hmm
and that's that's kind of a different
opinion but Jesus overturned tables
because of corruption and the story of
the Good Samaritan I think coincides
with Bernie Sanders example look of
health care that helps should be given
to anyone who needs it even if that
person who needs it happens to be your
enemy that it's a right it's not a
privilege and so I guess my question is
why does the right seem to have a
monopoly on religious principles even
though you know the person is
representing the right right now and
Donald Trump seems to completely disavow
anything you know any of the core tenets
even of like Christianity I think that
Jesus was a lot more like Bernie yeah
basically two reasons in the way there's
two reasons for that
the reason number one is called being
first and reason number two is called
abortion so what I mean by that is that
the the right and the evangelical
Christian community specifically became
intertwined with the Republican Party
decades ago and so oftentimes when
something happens first would there's a
first mover advantage and even though
you know as a non-religious person
myself and someone who was raised you
know culturally Jewish it really doesn't
matter to me what it is anyone believes
Jesus thought did or felt I would agree
with you that if you look at the
teachings you can very reasonably come
away with the perspective you're coming
away with about Jesus Christ
now the other element of this is just
abortion which is the reason that the
evangelical Christian community was tied
in so early with the Republican Party
happened to be very tightly knit around
particularly the issue of abortion there
are many many one or two voters who just
care about abortion so when they hear
you talk about
Lamont you know health care or whatever
else it seems like Jesus would be more
on the side of the left
they just say abortion abortion abortion
abortion and that is a very thing to say
it works it's worked for decades you're
right for sure but hey thanks for your
thanks for your perspective on this one
David I appreciate your your work
all right Lamont appreciate the phone
call hope to hear from you again thank
you so much